DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
The problem I'd like
to work with you today
is the intersection of
two parametrized lines.
So we have two lines here.
L_1, given with
the parametrization
in terms of the variable t.
And L_2, also given
with the parametrization
in terms of the variable t.
So the first question
that I want us to answer
is do these lines intersect?
And if so, then we want to find
out where do they intersect.
So why don't you pause the
video and work on this.
And we can check
back in a moment
and we'll see how I solved it.
OK, welcome back.
Let's get started.
So we have these
two lines in space.
Before we start doing
any computations,
I find it useful
to draw a picture.
So let's see what's going on.
OK.
So we have these two lines.
We can just find some
common points on the lines.
So, well, if we put
in t equals 0 here,
then it looks like we
get the point 2 comma 1.
OK.
And now if we plug in, let's
say, t is minus 1 here,
then we get-- if we plug in t
is minus 1 here, we get x is 3
and y is 0.
So there's our line L_1.
And now let's see, L_2.
If we plug in t equals 0,
we get 2-- 1, 2, 3-- 4.
And if we plug in, let's
say, t equals minus 1 again,
then we get 1 and 2.
OK?
So there is L_2.
And indeed, it does look
like they intersect.
We could have probably
guessed that they intersect
by looking back over here at
the formulas for L_1 and L_2,
because we see that the
sort of direction that this
is moving in, we can
take derivatives in t.
And we see that L_2
is, this line is moving
in the direction 1 comma 2.
And L_1 is moving in the
direction minus 1 comma 1.
And so those directions
are not parallel.
And so we know that
the only way the two
lines could fail to intersect
is if they're parallel.
So actually, even
without drawing this,
we could have guessed that
these lines do intersect.
So now we know that
these lines intersect.
And in fact, it even
looks, you know,
it kind of looks like they
intersect-- from our sketch--
at the point-- it
looks like-- 1 comma 2.
It seems to be the
point of intersection.
But, you know, we got a little
bit lucky with our sketch here.
So let's see if
that's actually true.
Let's see if we can verify
this in the general way
that we discussed in lecture.
So, now there is one place
where we have to be careful.
We have two lines here, and
we parametrized both of these
with the variable t.
But we need to keep
in mind that t is
what's called a dummy variable.
It doesn't have any geometric
meaning to the problem.
And in particular, what I
want to caution you about
is if we just start
solving these two
equations algebraically
as they're
given to us with the
variable t, the problem
that we could run into
is that, you know,
we're sort of
moving-- as we vary
t-- we're moving along this
line, and as we vary t again,
we're moving along this line.
And you see we're
moving at the same time.
And so that's really
solving a different problem.
That's not asking about when
did these lines intersect,
but that would be
asking about when
do two particles on these
lines collide, which
is a harder problem.
So instead, what
we need to do is
we need to give a change of
variables for the line L_2.
So what I want to do is I'm
going to write L_2-- I'm just
going to write the
same equations,
but I'm going to introduce
a new variable u.
So x is 2 plus u,
and y is 4 plus 2u.
OK.
So now once we've done that, to
find the point of intersection,
well, the point
of intersection is
going to precisely
be a point on L_2
where the x-coordinate
and the y-coordinate
agree with another point
on L_1 with the same
x- and y-coordinate.
So that is, we
have the-- what we
want to do is we want to set
the x-coordinate for L_2.
We want to set this equal to
the x-coordinate for L_1, which
is 2 minus t.
So this was for L_1.
And similarly here, we want to
set the y-coordinate for L_2
equal to the
y-coordinate for L_1.
So now if you think
about it, if we
can solve this system of
equations, then what we've done
is we've simultaneously
found a point which
is on L_1 and on L_2.
And that's our goal.
So that will be a
point of intersection.
OK, so now we just
have this system
of two linear equations
and two variables,
and we just need to solve it.
Now, we could do, you
know, the-- in general,
with an equation like this, we
might try to add or subtract
the equations.
But this one is
so simple, that I
see that the top equation
is just the same thing as t
equaling to minus u.
That's what the top equation
says if we cancel the 2's.
And so if we plug that
into the next equation,
then we get 4 plus
2u equals 1 minus u.
And so then we can
solve this, and we get,
so it looks like 3 equals
minus 3u, which tells us
that u equals minus
1, and then that
tells us that t equals plus 1.
OK?
So we found our
parameters t and u.
And we're not quite done yet.
What we need to do is we need to
go back to our parametrization.
So let me go back over to our
original parametrization here,
and we have L_1 was 2
minus t and 1 plus t.
And over here, we
found that t equals 1
was the value that we're after.
So that tells us that x is
1-- 2 minus 1-- and y is 2.
Excuse me.
I wrote that in a funny way.
x is 1 and y is 2.
Now, just as a reality check.
We also found that
if we solved for L_2,
we wanted the variable u
to be equal to minus 1.
So we had 2 plus
u, and 4 plus 2u.
And so let's see
what happens when we
plug in u equals minus 1 here.
We again get x equals
2 plus minus 1 is 1.
And y equals 4
plus minus 2 is 2.
So we just double check that
this is a point of intersection
of both lines.
And I'll leave it at that.